I keep going because I have to if I
don't do this we're going to die the day
of the incident we actually were having
a peace march this peace march was to
can bet all violence done at the hand of
another I was marching for my big
brother who was killed by the hands of
another person I was marching for Wilson
Pierre which is my best friend he was
killed as well we actually which is
walking around chanting and letting
people voice their opinions voiced and
hurt and pain my passion comes from me
actually losing a lot of people in my
life when my big brother died which was
in 2002 it caused me to just go full
throttle down the wrong road because I
felt like maybe just going to die anyway
so why do something to save your life
right and so once my best friend died in
2011 it actually woke me up so that's
why I started black lives matter
Pasadena to really focus on the
community that I grew up in because I'm
tired of putting my friends on my
t-shirts and I'm tired of putting them
as tattoos on my arm you know that like
this is what we do when someone dies at
least if I'm going to lose them i'm
going to die fighting for them to you
know what keeps me empowered is the love
and the people that i have around me see
I'm not doing this alone there's a whole
network of folks that show love and
support it's like a chain where you have
somebody right here and somebody right
here and when you deplete yourself from
your energy they pick you right on up it
is our duty to love and protect one
another I'm in my community our black
men are dying
so I just want everyone to send their
love and uplift black people because in
this society right now we have targets
on all of our backs not just mine and so
now we're trying to do trying to fight
back